Can you please explain how the rebuilder 300 works that have people had success with it helping with their
property from chemo that has been a 17% their sense loss in one and 27% loss in the other
so the rebuilder is a product that was created to help build back their loss so
if there's nerve loss, then the rebuilder can be a huge benefit to rebuild that back. On the rebuilder, let me pull it up really quick, on the rebuilder on the
store where it shows the rebuilder, let me pull that off here and I can show you what the unit looks like. It looks like a little 10's unit looks like this, but she
don't hook it up like a 10's unit like with pads sticky pads to your feet, you do it where you use rubber pads and you put them in two separate
a foot bath that has a split foot bath so not like the foot bath that you use for the iron cleanse but a foot bath that has a split in it like a like a tool tote and you fill those
up with water you put one foot in each one and then you put the pads one pad in each foot bath and you turn it out it'll feel like a 10's unit, this tingle, and it's stimulating the nerves at their specific
frequency for healing that can really help a better heal so if there is a, I have a video on exactly how it works on the website, so on the store site, you could actually
watch a video of me actually training my staff a number of years ago and explaining how you have large diameter afference and small diameter afference and what those different nerve fibers do if they function based upon how what they pick up at the receptor site so an afferent nerve picks up information at a receptor and brings it back to the brain there's two main different types of these type of nerve fibers
and that's what what neuropathy is is damaged to these nerve fibers so learning about these afferent large diameter and small diameter afferent nerves can be beneficial so watch that video that is on the rebuilder store on the site and that will help you understand how it works will it work with neuropathy with chemo will it will work with neuropathy with anything but if the
person is continuing to do chemo or has it worked on detoxifying chemo it's going to have less benefit so how do you detoxify chemo what are the best ways to detoxify chemo as it's settled in your feet and in your legs damage the neurons and your feet and legs is to use the iron pro weight so using the iron pro wave can be helpful to pull that out of your body and that could be
that can be you know a steppet healing now you have to rebuild the nerves and that's where the rebuilder comes in so the rebuilders a great tool we have used this
probably for 15 years and with really good success i will say that you could get worse before you get better because as you rebuild these
these afferent nerve fibers you will actually rebuild the small diameter afference first and those are
your pain fibers so a person can actually feel more pain oh i've been doing this for a month and my pain
is actually gotten worse that's actually a good thing because what happens is you lose the small diameter
afference first and then you have the large diameter afference and so you lose your pain fibers first
and then the large diameter afference are the ones that carry vibration carry um light touch and
carry hot and cold and then you'll lose those so then you will basically lose feeling in your feet
all together and you'll end up tripping and you'll be falling you might not have that
neuropathy quite so much but you'll be tripping and falling and that's really bad as you rebuild it you'll
rebuild the small diameter afference first therefore you'll start feeling pain
um we've had people complain over the decade of doing this like oh this has gotten worse my
pain is and we have to explain to them that yes you will feel pain first because you're rebuilding
those pathways and then you will once that LDA is coming to play the day inhibit the pain and
they explain that the video followed here to where all the two works